welcome to the women in public policy
program seminar series podcast at
bird Kennedy School
good afternoon and welcome
I'm Victoria butts in the executive
director of the women in public policy
program as many of you know here at the
center we focus on how do we close
involuntary gender gaps and the areas of
political participation education
Economic Opportunity and health and
today we're joined by the Connors Rob
professor of business administration at
Harvard Business School Kathleen McGann
she's one of our affiliated faculty she
works with us regularly and she is one
of the key individuals within the sector
that really focuses on women and
Economic Opportunity and looks at how do
we design key interventions to close
gaps for women and girls today she
speaks about it takes a family and a
country and she will walk us through her
material would you prefer to take
questions during our at the end during
and you will often read about Kathleen
begins work not just in academic
journals but also in the popular media
has been featured in The Boston Globe
The Wall Street Journal the New York
Times and we are so pleased that she's
part of our community and I turn it over
to Kathleen a couple years ago I
presented a very very very preliminary
version of this with just a little teeny
bit of the data and got lots of
wonderful suggestions so I'm quite
hopeful that this around will produce
more of the same this is still work in
progress so please feel free to make any
suggestions ask any questions all of
your questions will make the work better
so thank you very much for coming I'm
going to talk today about work that will
gradually evolve into two papers so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that I'm
going to throw
to slow me down or speed me up at any
point in time that it seems reasonable
but because there's so much data let me
first tell you what I'm going to tell
you at the very end in case that we have
to speed up to get there so as the title
suggests we are looking at role models
and how those role models affect
economic and more broadly welfare
outcomes both women and men and we're
thinking about role models at two levels
role models at home so it takes a family
and role models at the country level it
takes a country we operationalize role
models at home non traditional gender
role models as working moms so I'll tell
you a lot more about the data in a
minute but think about working moms as
the response to this question did your
mother ever worked outside the home for
paid before you were 14 years old before
you're 14 it's ever in whatever way
someone might interpret ever so possibly
someone might interpret ever as a day
but it's very unlikely but it doesn't
mean that your mom was a full time away
from home mom so it's like as we think
about it it's a really weak test right
because there's lots of variation on
this variable and very strong results
that I'll show you that at the country
level we're looking at female
parliamentarians and we tried to look at
female heads of state but it turns out
there's just not enough very female
heads of state and so we look at the
proportion of female parliamentarians
again before you were 14 years old so
averaged across your life between the
time you are born and 14 years old
what's the proportion of female
parliamentarians in your country at that
period of time okay so so that's the
non-traditional gender role models of
the country
what we find is that for the
non-traditional gender role models at
home these improve women's outcomes in
the workplace and I'll give you lots of
details about that and they increase
men's participation at home the flip
doesn't seem to be as true so it has a
working mom has much less effect that's
what women do at home although a little
effect and um working moms have their
little effect on men's outcomes in that
work so it appears to us to be a true
role modeling effect what is it that
women see at home when you see working
mom handling things that I'll talk more
about this and their sons see boys have
much more distributed work at home and
so start to participate in that at the
country level the results are somewhat
weaker and the strongest results have to
do with what happens at home so female
parliamentarians it looks like have some
negative effects on workplace outcomes
and then I'll show you those but very
positive effects on outcomes at home so
again it looks like a role-model effect
but it's reasonable for men to be
participating in activities at home and
it's reasonable for women to be sharing
those activities as role model at the
country level right so that's the
overall story of what I'm going to tell
you at all so we were driven to this
research as Victoria talked about we're
really thinking about what drives the
gaps in outcomes between men and women
and christine lagarde last year said the
21st century poses many challenges that
require new way of thinking and she went
on to say that none are more important
than the economic role of women image
she laid out three areas where the
economic role of women needs to be
studied and changed and that is what she
calls a three L's learning labor and
leadership as we know from lots of
recent research women's learning in the
sense of formal education it's doing
quite well so across the developed
countries women actually have more
education than men they do better in
school than men and this goes all the
way up to the postgraduate levels this
is much less true in the developing
countries so some of you have seen me
present some work where we're studying
education outcomes for girls in Zambia
and looking at the effect of negotiation
training on this education outcomes in
the developing world girls still receive
much less education than boys but in the
developed countries this is flipped so
we're not going to look at learning from
a traditional perspective but rather
think about what learning goes on in the
household so again thinking about
learning as a role model effect and then
we'll look at labor in terms of the
likelihood of employment the like that
earnings that you have relative to
everyone else in your country if
employed and your likelihood of
supervisory responsibilities is our
measure of leadership we also because
much research has suggested that if we
don't change what goes on at home we're
never gonna get equal in terms of what
goes on at work we also look at outcomes
at home so rather than looking at just a
total aggregate hours spent at home we
look at hours spent and hustle work and
hours spent and family care and it turns
out that these have quite different
effects on earnings so I won't talk
about the effects on earnings here but
just a quickie that how many hours you
spend doing housework has a negative
their earnings across all of the
countries we study our spent in family
care have either no effect or a positive
effect on earnings and the sunset higher
earning people tend to spend more hours
and weekend in family care and that may
be because they have more hours in so if
we think about the differences in income
I mean explain this graph to you because
you'll see a few of these so I'm
studying these effects across 25
countries these are data that were
provided by the international social
studies program that's run out of
Germany the data are collected were
collected in 2002 and in 2012 and
they're collected across about 31
countries we use the 25 countries where
all of the data that we wanted to look
at are available for each country we
look at the differences between male and
female in many of our variables
sometimes well look at the difference
between years sometimes a look at the
difference between mother worked and
stay-at-home mom so for each country you
often will see two different variables
and then on our y-axis our y-axis is
always explained over here so in this y
access what we have is the standardized
in poems so it's standardized by country
by year so we take everyone who
responded to the survey in that year and
we put the mean at zero standard
deviation at one and what you see here
is that for every country for every
country women may clap
he's got a mind for every country women
make less that is it's lower so this is
zero is right in the middle parents so
anything below zero is the status below
the mean anything above zero is above
the mean so what we have is women in
every country making less than men there
are some countries where it's more even
than others so in ways that you wouldn't
be surprised we see in the Slavic
countries we don't see women's income
being so much lower than men's but I'm
sorry in the Nordic country countries
and we also don't see it as a very low
income country so it tends to be that in
the real low income countries you don't
get that gap because everybody's making
some little so this is what we're trying
to explain we do know that gender
inequality so we can see between 2002
and 2012 that gender inequality is
shrinking but is shrinking somewhat
unevenly so this is that this is just
for women so everything is below zero so
the zero line is right here so for women
you can see that in most countries with
a notable exception being the u.s.
women's income relative to the income of
women and men is getting the gap is
getting smaller
so did you see like a different
differential back of the financial
crisis
yeah so it's a great question I wish we
could the data are collected only in
2002 and 2012 so for those of you who
don't know is SP data it's fantastic
ninis that they collect data every year
they collected across about 30 countries
every year but what they collect every
year is different so they first started
collecting the gender related data in
1988 I collected in 88 94 2002 and 2012
so we don't have these data infer from
this data source
and inequalities are also widespread in
the private sphere so you can think
about the public sphere and being the
workplace the private sphere being home
and what we see here are the hours the
hours spent weekly on household tasks
and this goes from zero hours to 40
hours a week and what you see is that
across all of the countries we see women
doing more work at home than men do
again in the Nordic countries this is
more equal what you also see is it tends
to be that the more developed the
country the less time is in aggregate
spent at home and what we see is
basically as you bring in things like
dishwashers and wash machines and you
have to spend you don't have to spend as
much time at home so the common
household tasks in family care yep so
this is just household tasks so there
are yeah so there are two separate
questions the question for household
tasks is how many hours a week do you
spend on and it's shopping laundry
cleaning household repair and other
tests
what about I say what are you doing on
there's cooking Thank You in for a
family care the question is how many
hours a week do you spend caring for
family members for all of the family
care analyses all show we only include
people with children but people without
children have non 0 family care as well
we don't include those in these emails
and all the data self reporting all the
data is self-report so one of the one of
the things that we did just look at
especially though within household data
is we looked at a country level and we
said ok on average in this country how
many hours do women say they spend at
home and then men were asked how many
hours does your spouse spend and then
women were asked how many hours do years
who is your spouse spend and what we
found was that women women's reports of
men's hours were roughly the same
they're not significantly different
men's reports of women's hours were
significantly different in that women
were reporting fewer hours of men were
reporting for their spouses and I've
seen other studies that show men tend to
over report and this isn't a critique
this is just what the what the data
describes the fact that men tend to over
report household care and that women
tend to underreport their household care
so that and there's and there's some
recent research run 2012 that compared
all of the various ways that you can
collect data about household work so
some of it self report some of its time
diaries and it tends to be that across
these methods the numbers are roughly
the same so so it's not it's not perfect
sure but it's capturing it's pretty good
yeah puzzles information yeah great
question
so the ISSP every year tries doing does
pretty well a stratified random sampling
at the country level
so across urban suburban rural across
income levels across districts and I'll
show you the numbers we have roughly in
countries somewhere between 500 and 1500
per country so no it's not it's not a
great number but they try to have it be
a pretty stratified
so the thesis from which we're working
is that gender inequality at work cannot
calm doesn't reflect anything hard-wired
about men or women nor does it
necessarily reflect only things that are
policy related at the country level but
rather reflects individual attitudes
reflects experience that people have had
in their lives reflects the bargaining
that people do at home and at work and
reflects the legal and social cultural
influences in the broader society so we
consider childhood exposure to women
providing non-traditional role models
and we explore the association between
that and outcomes in the public sphere
in the private sphere so our research
question is whether and we know this by
this point because I told you the answer
is on whether it affects employment
supervisor responsibilities earnings
allocation of household work and care
for family members so you can think
about this as our model but this model
has only direct routes I'm going to talk
a little bit about what we thought would
be a mediated model sense of we know
about gender role models at home is that
they have had a gender attitudes and so
we believed that there would be some
mediation there and there is past work
on the role of non-traditional gender
role models at home so we know that we
know from a very few studies but that
working mothers do affect the allocation
of household work this appears to work
through the mail even
the few studies that are out there
before ours and in an interesting study
that use an instrumental variable
Fernandez and her colleagues looked at
the proportion of men who were sent away
there who who went to war in World War
two and used that as an instrument to
say how likely was it that women in that
area were going to be employed during
that period of time and then use that to
say what happened to their sons spouses
now why they were with their sons
spouses instead of just their daughters
is a little unclear to me but they look
at the effect on their sons spouses in
it what they find is that men who were
raised by using this instrumental
variable women who worked were more
likely to be married to spouses who
worked as well we also can think about
non-traditional gender role models not
just as working moms but housekeeping
dads and there are some studies that
look at the men's allocation of the
allocation of household work to dance
and it looks like these make kids gender
attitudes more liberal it looks like
this lasts a long time so it affects a
not just the immediate gender attitudes
but affects gender attitudes when these
kids are adults it also there's quite a
bit of research on gender attitudes
it looks like gender attitudes get
pretty fixed by the time you're an adult
they'd be keen they become somewhat more
liberal with some shocks that I'll talk
about and somewhat more conservative
with things like getting married and
having children of an in general your
gender attitudes are pretty well shaped
by the time you're an adult
at the society level
the evidence is much sparer there is an
interesting study that in the u.s. that
looked at media coverage of female
politicians and what it what those
findings suggest is that to the extent
that there's media coverage this does
affect teenage girls from gender
attitudes around politics but it appears
to affect it through conversations at
home so it appears that the mediator is
whether it's sort of discussed over the
dinner table in a recent study by Esther
Duflo and her colleagues they looked at
the random assignment of a panchayat in
India so India has put essentially
quotas on the proportion of villages
become of mrs. cities that have female
mayors that has to be once every three
years
or once every three election cycles and
what they find is pretty remarkable
effects on gender gaps in terms of
attitudes and pretty good effects in
terms of what actually goes on at home
and what they see is that that the
villages in which there were multiple
years of female mayor's that the gender
gaps and aspirations actually go away so
so there is there is some evidence that
non-traditional gender role models at a
societal level make a difference notice
that this is mediated by what's going on
at home so you can think about that as a
role model effect it's not simply that
you have women running but how you
discuss what those women running mean
and Duflo and colleagues actually end
their paper by saying because it seems
to have very little effect on things
like employment
comes we're assuming that this is
actually a role-model effect that's
their words not mine
Kenny its theorem is it important that
these societal role models have made
public political I'm just wondering why
you know if you had a society where all
the doctors women are the track records
where there's a it it's is it the path
the public nature important yeah it's a
great question um so it's both a
question of the practicality of research
and the visibility of the people so so
in terms of the practicality of the
research it's very hard to get good
numbers historical numbers of women
across these industries the other thing
is it's hard to figure out what numbers
we fought about doing things like CEOs
but if you're using a representative
sample of the population like me yeah
like do people really know what
proportion of email said I mean we do
write the people is room too because we
keep repeating the number over and over
again no matter how depressing it is um
but but it was hard for us to come up
with an argument about why women CEOs
somehow we're gonna make a difference
across across all of society you could
think about things like female
professionals that everybody sees so
doctors
but it's really hard to come up with
something that's as visible the other
difference between these and I think
it's enticing to your question is this
is much more immediate
alright so mayor's tend to be much
better known at a sort of visceral level
than people at the national level but
there's very little research out there
even with this and and actually none
that I know of that looks at it in the
private sector
so the way that we think these
non-traditional role models work is that
they shape what people think is
appropriate behavior so if you're if you
think about different ways of thinking
about how gender works you can think
about it outside biological models you
can think about it as a social a
socialization model you can think of it
as a pure exposure based model that is
what I see I come to think about and
believe as normal so that's the approach
we're taking here did this just change
it looks very fancy so so traditional
gender attitudes essentially place men
and women in separate spheres so women
spheres at home and men sphere is in the
workplace and you can contrast that to
more egalitarian gender well models
where women and men share the homemaking
and the workplace roles and of course
this is a continuum and there are some
that argue that this is actually not a
continuum at all but two separate scales
we're going to treat it as a continuum
it's the way that it was asked and I'll
tell you a little bit more about but
about the specific questions I can't
tell you that it's very hard to find
cute Carty cartoons are not men and
women sharing roles and businesses and
favorites
there we go so so what we proposed is
that the gender role models of the
family are actually going to work
through gender cattitude we'll start
with that and go from there
these are the data I think I've talked
about all of this these are the
countries so this goes to your question
of how many observations so it's not
because I carried out every year and a
survey these surveys are done in person
in the household so the sir nays take a
couple hours and they cover lots of
months a lot of questions the one thing
to notice that post-soviet countries the
numbers are quite small the post-soviet
countries are interesting for other
studies we're doing with these data in
these analyses if you drop them you
don't get anything different you don't
in the data said do you have single
month
yep
and as I go through the analyses I'll
tell you who's included in which
analyses for the for the workplace and a
third from I'm sorry for the home
analyses we only use people who were in
those in couples
so here are the characteristics as
little over half female around 40 years
old
religion is a categorical variable the
most important thing is that the the
emitted variable is no religion so and
you'll see there are some religions as
we go through the analysis Mary
cohabiting about a little over half a
little over half have children and about
1/3 have little kids at home about half
our urban over 50% had that their mom's
worked before they were 14 and the
average proportion of women in
Parliament when they're under 14 is
around 11 note that all of these with
the double asterisks the difference
between men and women is significant
highly significant because we're looking
at around 50,000 observations we we use
cut-offs at 0.01 if it cutoff is any
lower than that I'll tell you just we're
running so many analyses we have so much
data 0.05 would be a fishing expedition
in terms of employment you can see a
major difference between men and women
over 80% of men and not quite 70% of
women are employed again this is the
standardized income so men's income is
generally above the mean women's income
is generally below the mean with about
the same standard deviation in terms of
supervisory responsibilities again we
get much higher supervisory
responsibilities from men for women
we've been putting in lots more hours of
household work and lots more hours of
care so these data are I think as you
would expect and again men and women are
significantly different on all of these
so now the question is do the
non-traditional gender role models
matter for all of this so we'll first
look at gender role models in the family
and I'll use this to explain not only
the outcomes for this but essentially
how we looked at the data so I'll go a
little bit more slowly through this
analysis than I will through the rest of
the analyses to gender attitudes are
measured with these 11 questions so some
of them are sort of agree strongly
disagree to strongly disagree for
example men's job is to make money
women's job is to look after the home
some of them are the reverse so working
mothers can have a warm relationship
with their children just the same as
mothers who stay at home do and then a
couple of the questions have to do with
what do you think women should do so
what do you think women should do when
their children are under school age and
what do you think they should do when
the youngest starts mom in terms of
whether they should stay at home or go
to work we ran a random factor analysis
on this they load together quite well
alpha
point seven seven and so we kept them
together we have run some separate
analyses looking at these as a separate
group of questions because they really
are getting at what seems to be a
somewhat different construct even though
they're highly correlated with this I
won't go into those analyses they don't
seem to say much different
so here are the gender attitudes and the
thing to notice basically is that for
the most part and again these are these
are z-score sorry these are standardized
scores because it's a scale and some of
the items of the scale have different
measures I'm sorry have different scales
and so basically what you see is that
women tend to be a little more
egalitarian so higher as more
egalitarian lower is a more traditional
women tend to be a little bit more
egalitarian than men across most of the
countries average is cross country
across all yep so it's standardized to
serve around the world
standardized no no I just thought income
Western yeah yeah yeah we're good room
with the dollars yep yep so so hearing
the question this is across all of the
data where do these countries fall so
you can see for example that Norway if
you look at it relative to rest of the
world is much more egalitarian and you
can see that Mexico for example is much
more traditional
importantly if you just look at the
left-hand side of the graph if you look
at male and female you can see that
females are much more egalitarian than
males this is the sample of people whose
moms stayed at home full-time this is
the sample of people whose moms were
employees you can see a whopping
difference here so that even for the men
if your moms employed you have more
egalitarian gender attitudes than women
whose mom stayed at home Vanessa's
across the world and Kathleen you had
indicated at the beginning of the talk
that for the men who grew up in a
household where the mother was employed
so we can see they're like enough social
benefit and then their spouse so to
speak would likely be able to earn more
money presuming that then their value
system Kerrigan's the household so if
it's a dual earner income household they
may see an economic benefit from a
household perspective but there's no
particular benefit to them and their
career looking at the economics of it is
that right from what you're doing yep
that's right
yeah there's no there's no harm no gain
right
so you can so this is mom at home and
not employed across the countries and
what you can see is that this holds true
in every country so for every country if
your mom was employed before you were 14
you have more egalitarian gender
attitudes so we will control her country
level effects but this is this
essentially doesn't vary in the country
level so the reason I'm showing you all
these numbers is because I'm doing it
just once to show you what I did so that
so so we ran a mix we've run a mixed
effects model which means we control for
essentially the country level effects in
the country level women in Parliament so
these are random effects everything here
is fixed effects here the other
religions we look at Christian Jewish
Islamic and Buddhist Hindu another in
terms of gender attitudes what you can
see is relative to people who said they
have no religion or practice no religion
with the exception of Jewish everybody
else is more traditional in terms of
their gender attitudes relative to
people that they said no religion again
unsurprising we know that religious
activity tends to be correlated with
more traditional attitudes around balls
pulse
Thanks
older people are less egalitarian
married people doesn't matter you become
less egalitarian once you get married
I'm sorry once you have children I'll
show you some good things about caring
for family members but there's quite a
bit of literature that suggests that
households and all of us who actually
went through this notice households have
what they call a shock to the system
once children come into the household so
it's not about the caring for household
our caring for children per se but it
doesn't rearrange things in the
household and part of the way it
rearranges edges it makes you sort of
fall into a traditional gender roles
people in urban areas are are more
liberal more liberal over time so much
of the specifics on this but in almost
all of the countries gender attitudes
are becoming more traditional this I'm
sorry more liberal between 2002 and 2012
this goes counter to some research that
suggests that things are stagnating
promote we can see things are getting
better over time women have more
egalitarian gender attitudes and for
those of you for those who were raised
by working mom important much more
egalitarian gender attitudes so these
are the kind of analyses will run on
everything I won't show you the rest of
the regressions
so first we're going to look at
employment and supervisor
responsibilities given employment so
this is the likelihood of employment the
difference between women and men and we
see that in most of the countries
there's some women are less likely to be
employed than men again in the more
egalitarian countries that differences
minimize but it's still there so for all
of these what I'm going to basically
show you is just the the marginal
effects controlling for everything that
I just talked about these are the
marginal effects for having been raised
by a working mom so what we can see is
that if we look at these so that this
color really starts so this is a red
line these are females this is a blue
line these are males so for males this
is a non significant effect but for
females being raised by working mom
controlling for all of those other
things increases your likelihood of
being employed and all these look like
steep lines the effect for some reason
is most significant on females that the
vet being raised in a race at a time
where there were higher female
parliamentarians increases your
likelihood of employment
Oh even wait
okay so now we look for those people who
are employed what's the likelihood of
supervising other people at work and
again we see that women are much less
likely to supervise than men are across
across all of our countries and again
controlling for everything else but we
again see is that the effect of having a
working mom is flat for men and in
significant and increasing for women so
those those who are raised by working
mom are much more likely to supervise
others at work than those who were
raised by mom who stayed at home the
effects of the female parliamentarians
is negative so that the more female
parliamentarians when you were a kid the
less likely you are to supervise others
and we're trying to sort out why that is
so what we see we had this up here
gender attitudes are not meeting
mediating these effects so I don't have
the regressions in here so I can't show
you but gender attitudes are always
significant but the effects for working
moms and the effect for female
parliamentarians stay even after you put
gender attitudes in there so gender
attitudes are definitely affected by
being raised by a working mom but that
is not the full effect it seems that
there is some kind of modeling going on
I don't just change that what I believe
I change what I know and what I know to
do so there's some sort of skill based
thing that we think is
on here so there's a direct effect of
gender attitudes and a direct effect of
the gender role models now if we look at
income you've seen this number and what
we see is that being raised by a working
mom again has no effect on men's income
and it increases women's income this is
a little bit lower than the significance
level that we've seen on other things
point zero nine this effect is mediated
by gender attitudes so if you take
gender attitudes out of the equation
this is a whopping least deep effect
once you put gender attitudes in the
effect for working mom remains
insignificant but not significant at the
same level who's there enough single
female head of household with children
in the sample to show students
statistically significant effects so if
I just run it only on single single
female head of household I can run
whatever
I think that could be interesting
in some countries I won't have enough
data but I can pull out just those
countries that have enough data I can do
what's your hypothesis that's the kind
of thing I would wanted before I would
be careful of making a narrative and a
story before I saw if there was data
that supports there's a narrative her
story so in my mind I would try to not
think too much in advance on that but
couple effects when I think about
looking at wage data for example when we
looked at the countries and attitudes
interesting to see the US as attitudes
compared to other countries for example
and looking at attitudes and wages since
I spent a lot of my time focusing on
wages we now know that every major city
in the US is or will be
majority-minority for example and what
we also know is that single female head
of household with children is huge it's
for example Boston proportion of yeah
most children of Boston will grow up in
single female head of household and if
we're looking at what and you're saying
there is an effect on whether or not
there's a gala tearing values well if
the woman by definition is the
breadwinner and the caretaker right then
in essence it's no longer about whether
or not it's viewed as equal it's really
viewed as only only and how can she
handle it so I think what the what what
we see beyond gender attitudes is not
about beliefs in equality but rather
about figuring out how to
alright so if your mom worked when you
were a kid you see how she does it I
know what brought it to mind as he
talked about skill building effects
right and children who grow up in
households I presume with one parent and
a single female head of household to
some extent I'm gonna presume there's
skill building and competency taking
place for the children and then you can
map it on to anecdotal things like you
know past two Democratic presidents have
both been male grow up in single female
head of household both had to develop a
skill set where they could both be
personable they could be effective in
school they both had some effect of
idolizing the mother and therefore that
transitive policy which is there for
interest yeah for us yeah you know how
do we create male leaders who have a
lens towards productive what I would
view is talent management and productive
equality policy yes so that's what's
running out there my mind these
respondents mothers were single head of
household we have whether the
respondents are Seminole head of
household so I can see whether the
effect of being raised by working mom is
different for women who are in
two person had a household at four one
two two parents one but I can't see
whether you were raised by a single mom
in terms of gender any I'm sorry in
terms of income inequality what we see
is that for both men and for women and
the proportion of female
parliamentarians when you were a child
is associated with lower earnings and
again we're trying to figure out what
that is so what we see is again direct
effects for employment and supervisor
responsibilities on role models at home
for women positive effects of employment
on role models at the country level
negative effects for women and men in
terms of supervisors responsibilities
and earnings the effect of role models
at home for earnings only is mediated
partially by the gender attitudes
you couldn't quite explain about having
more female parliamentarian and lower
earning I mean I don't know the data for
what this cohort was 14 and younger but
if you look today at the IPU data of who
has the highest proportions there's a
lot of really low income countries in
there and I wonder if it's a correlation
right what exactly is the use that
compared with in country or is that
comparative to the mean of yeah so what
we do is so we have the random effects
for country we have the random effects
no female parliamentarians at the
country level at the current level of
female parliamentarians and then we
allow individual fixed effects but
female parliamentarians when you were a
kid okay but there is but I completely
agree with you that there is something
going on it's within country or is it
between you know it cuz it's across
countries controlling for the random
effects of current level of female
parliamentarians but I think what we
need to do and I think this is what
you're alluding to there are more
parliamentarians or female and nations
were the barriers to entry and that this
is so much skewed now by quotas but
where the Parliament is part-time or
underpaid or low status which usually
means poor economy yes I'm only gonna do
with that and what we haven't put in yet
but we're going to put in essentially
gender inequality indeed yours
to your level so we just got all those
data from separate data sets so so we're
trying to figure out whether we should
put gender inequality data at the time
you were under 14 or in the current time
you might try might try both but I
completely agree with you that there's
something like that going on there
so if we think about gender inequality
in the private sphere we know that it's
affected by gender inequality in I'm
sorry generating quality in the public
sphere we know it's affected by gender
inequality in the private sphere so
Hannah and I have a paper that looks at
this as a two-level game that your
negotiations at home are affected by and
affect your negotiations at work and
there is this recursive system between
what's happening at home gender
attitudes and what's happening at work
and then back again what's happening at
work gender attitudes and what's
happening at home and we're going to try
to tease this out and separate out work
and family care the allocation of
household work has quite a bit of
research around it that the earliest
research was based on Becker's model
that thought about the household as a
monolithic decision maker in essence
everybody in the household wanted what's
best for the household and you stayed
home if it was best for the household
you went to work but was best for the
household we've somehow since the ADA is
grown to realize that probably
individuals in the household might have
their individual preferences that aren't
necessarily all aligned at the household
level and so more recent models allow
for differences
princes across across decision makers in
the household this work suggests that
relative resources and time availability
have big effects on how the allocation
of household work is determined and so
we have a separate paper where we're
looking at that as well
these things have relative resources and
time availability interact with whether
your mother worked or not
they study for a separate day there is
also quite a bit of work that shows that
what's going on in the country level
affects what happens within people's
households um what I think is the
interesting piece of this and what
Hannah and I thought was the interesting
piece of this when we looked at
bargaining at home is a to earn
career home bargain is to local games is
that negotiations at home are a right
setting for essentially turning
understandings of roles and so I think
it's a a very important place to study
even though we don't think of it
necessarily as a place of economic
outcomes in in practice it
being raised by a working mom and so
here we start to see this interactive
interaction effect so for women being
raised by working mom reduces the number
of hours you spend in household work it
increases the number of hours that men
spend in household work and these
effects also hold for female
parliamentarians so for men who were
raised in countries where there were
more female proletarians when they were
kids they tend to do more hours of
household work women fewer hours of
household work caring for family members
is actually quite different so if you
think about the economic explanations
they hold for housework and for care
work but there's very different cultural
expectations about caring for family
members and so we can if we think about
separating these apart we can think
about a number of reasons why we would
expect different effects and eat within
each country unlike household work hours
and family care actually increasing and
this this looks to be true across most
of the countries that we study and this
is in spite of the fact that there's
many fewer kids per household than there
were a couple decades ago it's
increasing Provo's women and for men and
the increase for men is substantially
bigger than the increase for women so
with household work it's going the
opposite way men are doing more women
are
less and women are doing much less than
men are doing more but that's because we
have half that we have sort of labor
saving devices coming in but for house
for care both people are doing more it
does so so the question is how many
hours a week do you spend caring for
family members we cannot differentiate
between aging parents and kids what we
do is we include in the analyses I'll
show you we only include people who have
kids at home so they may also have aging
parents but it's probably much less
likely than if we look at the host
we could restrict it to an age range
sort of 40 and above that would have
aging parents we didn't do that well he
couldn't do that with you know
right
may experience some
uh interested most of these studies so I
call this family care almost all of
these studies are just caring for kids
our data includes both most of these
stones are basically just to the kids
sorry do you see a difference between
the profession as a parent so we have
very some growth industry measures so I
don't know that you just I don't know
the actual professions of these people
and I don't control for it
also be explained by if a family has
more children their age if it could be
what it looks like when you look across
these studies that some of these are
ethnographic much more qualitative
studies it's just the the expectations
around Heretic have really changed
in terms of how much time you spend with
the child
I think everyone in this room is younger
than I but you know five 105 and
basically it wasn't like we were all
within seven years so it was like anyone
has taken care of anyone else but was
pretty much you know it's like go
outside and play
it was like we were being driven to this
and that and and even the language the
term parenting the idea that parenting
was an act rather than just a state of
being
before you were a parent but if you look
at certain linguistic constructions like
parenting is a new term to sense where
that what bucket those hours were in
prior to being shifted into Karen Weaver
is it is it now that younger younger
children the household have to do fewer
hours and those hours of accumulated
that mother and father or that it's
shifted away from their labor it's a
really big question it shifted away from
housework hours so so if you take the
housework hours and the family care
hours and you add them together that
doesn't seem to be changing very much
and so what you'll see is what
washing machines and refrigerators yeah
yeah so and it's a part of the reason
that mothers used to say go outside to
play was that they were really busy and
and they didn't have Trader Joe's
so so it was a very different allocation
of time so so what we see is that being
raised by a working mother equally
increases women's and men's hours spent
in family care
so unlike allocation of household work
we're being raised by a working mom made
nurse or taught women how to do less
housework and hit men how to do more
housework being raised by a working mom
increases both men's and women's time
that they spend with their kids
interestingly gender attitudes are not
related and you can think about this as
sort of reasonable the more traditional
people think that that's their role
they're supposed to be parents of the
more egalitarian people think you know
oh I should be spending time with my
kids so that I can teach them how to be
so what you see is nothing for gender
attitudes and positive for both men and
women in terms of a working mom in terms
of female parliamentarians no effect on
women whatsoever but countries kids boys
raised when there were more female
parliamentarians tend to spend more time
with their children
so what we see is not a median and model
but rather an attitude model of
non-traditional gender role models and
the effects on public and private sphere
outcomes so for women being raised by a
working mom increases touching increases
your earnings increases your supervisory
responsibilities both if you're working
and increases the base rate at which
you're likely to be working for men it
affects their outcomes at home so it
affects the amount of time they spend in
household work more time spent at
household work more time spent in family
care for women
it also affects these but it reduces the
hours that they spend in household work
so in some ways you could think about
this as a good news good news story so
there are very few what I think of as
sort of the magic bullets around
reducing gender gaps but it does look
like being raised by a working mom is
one of those magic bullets so increases
women's outcomes in employment doesn't
affect men's it increases men's
contributions at home and to the extent
that you're talking just about household
work decreases women's so the gaps here
are reduced in the gaps here reduced by
reason by being raised by a working mom
gender role models at the country level
appear to be somewhat more mixed with
negative outcomes in terms of
supervisory responsibilities in
both women and men but positive outcomes
when we think about outcomes at home
mostly for men but for women as well
Wow
so we haven't so we we actually
discussed doing this but because we have
people in here up to sixty years old so
we only include working age people to be
included in eighteen to sixty year olds
we would have to go back to the media
presentations when we were 14 years old
to go back 60 years media collect it
every year so that's probably
impractical but I think what we can do
is go in and put in the women's
empowerment index for those countries by
year it's not perfect so we spent the
last couple months trying to get all of
the data across a whole bunch of indices
to - to deal with essentially this
question and we have it it's a little
bit spotty in some countries when you go
back prior to World War two it's
especially spotty for obvious reasons in
the post Soviet bloc countries because
they weren't countries if they weren't
countries until much later and so we
don't have perfect data for it but we'll
run tests with as many controls as we
can to try to get out that because
you're absolutely right but just having
women a parliament doesn't mean
you does a positive thing by society
need to somehow figure out how to get
done just
I was wondering if you might want to
look at how these effects and mechanisms
my
different hospital levels as I imagine
would be willing to say perhaps
maybe to do a case study and what these
look like a different income levels and
also like let those
yes so so we do have people are calling
babies and broomsticks but people tell
me that makes me think about witches
presentation paper but what we what we
do in that is interact working mom with
income and with hours worked and and
you're absolutely right it also tends to
vary by the type of country that we're
in so in those analyses what we do is we
look at the gender attitudes at the
national level
both the absolute level and the change
over time and it looks like in the more
egalitarian countries the effect of
having a working mom doesn't it's
basically just about ours and income
it's not about that interacting with
working moms but when you get into what
we call the stagnating moderates that
feels like the US for example and the
stagnating conservatives on countries
like Mexico what you see is that being
raised by working mom as a signature
interaction with income and hours worked
and this is on what happens at home so
so your intuition is right what we would
love to be able to look at maybe this
isn't quite a new question is the income
of the household in which you were
raised so with my co-author Maya
Castro we are we started a big study in
Mexico Mexico is a huge outlier here
it's an outlier on a whole bunch of
dimensions it's very very conservative
it's one of the few countries where
women's gender attitudes are more
conservative than men's gender attitudes
it's one of the few countries where at
both hours spent in household work and
hours spent in family care are very high
and so we're working with 10 companies
in Mexico to try to see the extent to
which what happens at work can affect
what happens at home and their we're
able to look more closely first of all
at interactions with individual level
income and we're able we asked questions
about the household in which you were
raised
so how conservative was it was it of
digesting a mom what was your we have
these sort of status
sooner some things and we don't have
those
yeah it's also Mexico's interesting
along with a few other countries there
are some fairly low income countries the
Philippines is one of these for example
where you don't have to be very high
income to have lots of help at home so
so in Mexico once you're just barely
above the poverty level then you start
having household help and so we're
trying to disentangle the role of that
as well yeah on that - same thing one of
the things that strikes me is that
actually these
institutions across countries yeah and I
support literature and mail welfare
state breadwinner state that's what it's
called down kind of the welfare order
that place is their child care isn't
their child care how long is the daily
hours of time kids spent in school yeah
when do they come home in other words is
they decide to organize in such a
fashion to make women's labor force
participation easy or not and in the
post-soviet countries in a way are we
really and she stick the rail and he
Corelli it's such a nice natural
experiment I hadn't looked at what was
in place in the Western ways place the
East which had vast amount of child care
writers also women working with such a
normal thing
so I mean it just strikes me out that
that should matter that would be a
an interesting way to get at these very
mistresses
so these are the types of data we're
trying to collect you can't collect them
from the post-soviet yes because yes
right because they didn't collect data
at that level one of the things you're
talking about and this is this was
striking in fact I I went back to the
day of like these can't be right
so so we have the proportion of women
who were currently working because we
have this data and we have the
proportion of people who report that
their mothers were working and in these
Soviet bloc countries way higher
proportions reported that their mom's
working than currently work which for me
is a flag right how can that be you know
but it's true almost all of those
countries and so it looked like that
should be that could be a boundary
condition for these effects it doesn't
appear to be but I agree with you there
was some really interesting and there's
not that much data on them we don't have
that much data on them either but it
would be interesting to pull them out
let them look at them separately
they tend to be like me in those babies
of broomsticks they tempt a cluster in
the stagnating conservatives so they're
changing very slowly the one country
which is bizarrely different than the
rest of Slovenia he's looked that's the
beauty is like the Nordic country it's
just I have the Slovenian friend who's
like this power woman she's the TV
broadcaster and
I wish we did we don't have it if you
know of any data sets that look at that
internationally I would love to see you
know I it's not asked even in the 2012
data so so the questions got more
refined it's really quite an interesting
study just to look at the gender
attitude type questions that they asked
in the 80 88 won the 94 won the 2002 in
2012 there's a whole study that you can
think of in terms of international
narrative around gender just for most
questions but even in 2012 they don't
ask if the dad stays at home
did you can I'm just thinking there with
the correlation of that with
it's public but like
you know the children made
professor you know doctor so how do you
control for unless those you have
specific some of the quota countries
they may not have
right so that them you have to come
together just yeah so so we have over
the last couple months collected the
data all the way back on to the if
something is available on what they call
female professionals so we do have
everything about female head of state
those are theirs it's just such a sparse
data almost everything's in zeros so
then we looked at whether there were
many who we had run for office and
gotten in the final run offs and even
that is too sparse so that we can't use
very much we do have women in
c-suites that's only reported in some
countries so we're going to try with
these new data to try to
to try to see if we can understand this
effect a little bit better but I don't
know where I don't know where it's gonna
lead us those those numbers by the way
tend to be the number you're talking
about in terms of female professionals
and people parliamentarians controlling
for nothing else they're actually big
Rafi
so there's but I would think in certain
countries
yes across the 25
so that might use
yeah you have really mixed
these other countries that are
yeah that's good enough
yes interesting so what we could do
which we hadn't thought about at all we
could essentially go in and find out
whether there's a photo it's easy to
just put in a dummy for a photo yeah
because I I think it's the mechanism the
mechanism may have a really significant
and I would actually do do it both with
quota and then what the quota reserves
seem like what that mechanism is now
because it mechanisms actually make a
pretty significant
one strong quota is yes
yeah I think yeah and we could treat
them as we could treat them as separate
or we could at least interact quota with
the that's a great idea did the pain
where the people asked if there are
female representation it is totally
separate Davison because my expectation
I mean most people have formed their
political identity by the time they're
about 18 to 20 so whether people are
flip assessed or not and all the data
shows that it does come from what was
discussed at the dinner table basically
yeah um this is before their 14th so
those are the numbers were reporting
here like I think Esther mohini's work
is spectacular but I don't think it's
likely broadly applicable because it was
very specific not about sort of gender
norms as much as it was about in those
communities would they want their
daughter to do something political right
and it might not have had yeah those
questions really what I'm a political
activist why I'm just so inspired I hope
it's taking away that mother's guilt but
she raised her two young girls with the
women doctor say
when they were a particularly young age
they turn on the television and saw
something quite unusual in turn that's a
mom no commend can be doctors so I
waited treatment the impact of women
sportscasters and when a women and all
those men medium their presence
normalizing the expectation but my
that's what our point that really
fascinates me but another is I did run
federally but now I'm very deeply
engaged in running boot camps and
training camps and orientation camps
from large numbers of women in Canada
specifically thinking about it and then
eventually engaging in it and how you
get into women do you change the game
where does the be MGM's you and then
it's very intriguing to me anecdotally
not yet time quantified but the numbers
of women who are entering into this
arena
what modeling did they have that made
them cross over that line in here
confidence or that determination
perseverance to do it a large number it
goes back to mother figures
for me running these camps and moves
this size across our country and
harvesting that kind of data it just
intrigues me some of the paradoxes that
you just brushed over
of the impact of parliamentarians how
are you going to dig deeper in them and
I'd love to talk it into the future yeah
yeah there's definitely some digging to
go there
so I'm the
how how salient is one gender above
words and sharing like ethnicity or like
in covering class background I mean does
having a bunch of members in Parliament
only belong to you know the social
majority or something have a different
impact on households with with people
that might not see them as a role model
by their gender first
so we don't know
as makeup of the female parliamentarians
it would probably not be a big stretch
to say it's probably
the majority of majority but it's a
really interesting question the the
other thing that we so so in terms of
the size of the fact for our working
moms relative to other things it's a
very very big effect the we don't have
race in there
the reason that we don't have race is
because it's it's different in every
country
so we could go in and try to put in
light-dark meter or some such thing but
different countries have actually
different questions in terms of race so
even at the individual level point we're
not controlling for race and I certainly
think it would have an effective that
would interact with some of these things
we haven't done it
that is a very necessary
we'd like to thank everyone again so
very much you all look forward to
reading the papers which will come out
of this and next week Paola who's with
us today we'll be presenting on pursuing
diversity in the legal market she's a
former women in public policy program
fellow and we're always very pleased
when she's able to join us so next week
Paola